hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay I have the
source of your power dick there it is
let me go try the odd tool on the door
just just to be thorough man I can't
believe how much stuff has been in this
custom story I mean seriously I think I
think like this custom story has enough
content to stand on its own as its own
expansion pack damn these it's just it's
really is an incredible thing that what
he's done and it's all been very very
interesting like I haven't gotten stuck
on hardly anything compared to some of
my other ones I've had help but you know
I've always had no need to grab this
sword before you oh okay sure yeah pick
up the holy sword that's funny it
doesn't look like it's full of holes
I'm interested in this this does seem
like it's going to be the end oh whoa oh
you have made it to me and he managed to
meet my other half in the lab yeah I
made him to meet I've gotta beat him to
a pulp with my fists father you'll pay
for what you have done you kill mother
my brother you killed every person in
town all that for what I killed your
mother and brother because I'm not your
father
we already met at the lab do you think
that little explosion would kill me
nothing can I'll do something for you
finger you can try to kill me or you can
join me by my side and rule the world
with me I guess I need to make a choice
I need to strike down my father or take
his side of the chair to the left
well since God this guy has been an
inescapable douche when Sara go that's
what I'm wondering since this guy has
been a bit of a douche I will choose to
murder his face get ready father
are you so naked and old tamed
[Music]
it's finally over then for my brother
mother evil is gonna happen
Donald Stevens that's the guys name do
need to t99 which is awesome cuz he's
been like commenting on my videos and
sending a message about this the entire
time this confederacies nightmare for
the heart was used for the heart a use
of the interrogation for the skyboxes
your wife for putting up with you oh we
got have that and me the player for
giving your game a try it is the best
the best custom story I have ever played
is so far above and beyond anything else
that it's in its own category this could
be its own game this guy should be hired
to make this stuff for frictional games
frictional games I don't I know they're
in fine not washing at all they don't
watch these let's play great thing on
that play
my goodness this was an incredible one
like just absolutely beyond incredible
and I'm gonna go back and try the end of
other ending so don't worry about that
I've got plenty of time in this one so
I'm gonna try the
I don't know they're pretty close
together so if it's not I'll just go out
and be in the back but yeah this has
been an incredible incredible let's
please I think it's like twenty seven
seven where there's like a third inning
maybe there's another toys in here to
actually end this once and for all if I
look around I'll do a little bit I'll do
that across because I've got plenty of
time I mean I'm gonna what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go do the other ending and
then I'm gonna come back and then try to
see if there's something else in here
because there just might be cuz I know
this guy like this like incredibly
detailed area here it's like outstanding
everything he's done is a fascinating so
join me and together rule the galaxy
okay
yeh sure point I made my choice rule
this world with his evil
everyone who's died you're born you
think I would let you help me I will
send you to the black abyss this makes
me thinks there might be something else
in here
[Music]
all notes and grammar grandma
but astronomic the grammar was great
compared to other custom stories have
played the grammar in this one was far
beyond all right I'm gonna go back in
I'm off fiddle around and look for Finn
hmm I wonder if there be a little little
something-something some some out there
because both endings ended in the main
character's death and no redemption so I
am wondering what was in the maze
masters office I'm curious I'm very
curious because I never got in there but
it seems like an important place you
know know what I'm saying know what I'm
saying so let me look around here flop
around the room a bit a blah blah you'll
never put it in town explode
don't ask me how it's raining blood but
that's pretty cool Yeah right
not quite methinks both choices are
maybe there was something in the
master's office that I was supposed to
get before I came in here and that's
oh wait no there was another pathway
over here pop I guess this is just
another way to get okay there doesn't
seem to be anything else around that use
this old man are we do told me
yeah no yeah oh what's up there
something that a little something thumb
that's something is a dancer some
function is doctor I'll see what he got
their exploit oh yeah super skilled oh
yeah look at me look at me go the best
oh I'm just the best there ever was
pretty much yeah
no one can beat me yeah Oh super oh it's
doesn't lead anywhere damn for something
maybe around the other ID
yeah uh-huh oh yeah
okay let's just go through here yeah
like it ain't no thing pop super scaled
oh I honestly don't think that there's
anything round here it really doesn't
look like it
[Music]
but I don't think so I really wish I
could figure out how to get into that
the master's office because I think
there's something in there that I might
need but you know it's hard to say I
mean I don't think I can go back through
the portal let me check to make sure
maybe running away as an option okay
that's not what I'm is amazing throw
myself to my death alright so um I don't
know
I don't know um I'm not sure I've got a
little bit of time left and just because
I want to be thorough about it I'm gonna
go back a save before I went in the
portal and I'm gonna try to get into the
master's office
I should put me before I think I think
he thinks but I don't know if you guys
know if there's something else I don't
find it out please right below in the
comments read the below in the comments
thank you - doom - 2099 for making this
incredible one and go like go find it go
find this yeah this is what I popped out
of left so let me put the father
Father's heart into the thingy and then
and then I would I mean I still have
this I still have a screwdriver maybe I
could stab the Masters door with this
holy sword yeah that makes sense and
where's Sarah
how does Sarah get to the door to the
house over there I'm so confused
I want to know how do I get in you how
do I open you up oh please tell me so
interesting secrets Oh glorious zebra
but tell me your secrets I don't know
and I don't feel like just fiddling
around so if you guys know I have a
feeling that there might be something
else
if not that's fine I'm just being a dick
walking around
if there is something else please write
below in the comments and anyway this
has been one of the best custom stories
I've ever seen and I'll probably nothing
will live up to this standard unless
doomed to two nine nine makes another
one so thank you everybody so much for
watching I know this has been a really
long one and I know that I said before I
started this I was gonna take a break
from an Anita but you know if I can keep
finding great custom stories like this
I'll keep playing amnesia for a long
long time so thank you everybody for
watching thank you dude to $2.99 we're
making it and as always I will see you
but I